well if you've been paying attention to
the news for the last 24 hours you've
probably already heard the blockbuster
revelation that Justin Bieber is now one
of the three artists to score
back-to-back number-one songs in the
United States twice I'm obviously
kidding that's not really news but we do
have really really big breaking news
here's the real breaking news Pat got
scared Pat thought I had changed the
first story on the show all of a sudden
now we've crossed some kind of red line
with Donald Trump's presidency it has
been revealed that Donald Trump in the
Oval Office the day after firing FBI
director James Comey Donald Trump
revealed highly classified intelligence
information to none other than Sergey
Lavrov the Russian Foreign Minister and
Sergey Kiss lyac the Russian ambassador
to the u.s. who is at the center of the
Trump Russia investigation and by the
way is also a suspected Russian spy
recruiter as first reported by The
Washington Post yesterday the
intelligence was related to an Isis plot
according to officials we know that the
information came from a Middle Eastern
ally that closely guards its own secrets
the information was considered so
sensitive that American officials didn't
share it widely even within our own
government
nevermind pass it on to other allies and
Trump spills it to Russia
now let's circumvent or step get around
one of the main questions first which is
is this strictly speaking illegal no
because the President does have the
power to declassify anything they want
to declassify so by sharing it Trump has
effectively Declassified it however this
is a major national security risk it is
a major diplomatic blunder it's a total
breach of espionage and intelligence
etiquette and protocol which could
drastically jeopardize our relationships
with other countries with regard to
intelligence sharing I mean Pat why
would any Ally share information with us
now Trump might just spill it to Russian
spy recruiters in the Oval Office I
think that is one of the most tell
like things because if we're not able to
give this to our allies apparently we
can give it to our adversaries yes but I
don't think it was that strategic it
seems as if Trump was trying to brag in
front of them and that's certainly what
the Washington Post article reflects and
I'm going to get to that because the
bragging aspect of this is big it's
actually even worse than I've even told
you so far because the ally that we
received this information from according
to an American official the ally had
already warned us that they would cut
off access to sensitive information like
this if we were to share it too widely
and I think Trump mentioning it to
Russian officials in the Oval Office
would constitute sharing it too widely
despite it not being illegal this is
also a mishandling by Donald Trump a
careless act of by Donald Trump with
regard to secret information so I think
we should go to none other than Donald
Trump himself in terms of how we should
deal with people who were careless with
sensitive information I will call your
attention to Donald Trump's tweet from
July 6th of 2016 where Donald Trump said
crooked Hillary Clinton and her team
were extremely careless and they're
handling a very sensitive highly
classified information not fit now the
controversy actually grew when General
HR McMaster Trump's national security
adviser initially denied the reports
which are being widely corroborated by
others McMaster said quote I was in the
room it didn't happen at no time at no
time were intelligence sources or
methods discussed and the president did
not disclose any military operations
that were not already publicly known
given how many bogus denials we've heard
from Trump cronies time and again this
isn't particularly convincing but Donald
Trump's own statements contradict
mcmaster donald trump sent two tweets
this morning where he said as president
i wanted to share with russia at an
openly scheduled White House meeting
which I have the absolute right to do
facts pertaining to terrorism and
airline flight safety humanitarian
reasons plus I want Russia to greatly
step up their fight against Isis and
terrorism
so Trump is not denying that he did this
he's basically saying hey I had
my reasons for doing it it seems like
very unorganized damage-control because
all these surrogates are saying
different things and even republicans
think this is insane
bob Corker who's a Tennessee senator or
Gabaldon who endorsed Trump early sure
said that he thinks that the White House
is in a downward spiral
you have Susan Collins a Maine senator
who said can we just have one crisis
free day so it looks like the wheels are
falling off spiral is not particularly
downward spiral but spiral alone is not
really a word you want being used to
describe your administration by people
within your own party and again there
have been conflicting reports but
according to officials Trump discuss the
contents of the intelligence not the
sources and methods used to collect it
official said that Trump shared granular
details of the intelligence with
Russians including the city in Syria
where the ally picked up the information
about the ISIS plot so again big picture
one of the people Trump shared this
information with is a Russian spy
recruiter suspected Russian spy
recruiter Sergey kis react here's
another blockbuster element of The
Washington Post report on this the
Washington Post story says quote one of
assistant to the president for Homeland
Security and counterterrorism Thomas P
Bossard subordinates also called and you
have to pay real close attention to this
called for the problematic portion of
Trump's discussion to be stricken from
internal memos and for the full
transcript to be limited to a small
circuit small circle of recipients
stricken from the internal memos and for
the full transcript to be limited this
suggests it basically directly says that
there is a full transcript of the
meeting the meeting was likely recorded
this could escalate very quickly if a
formal investigation begins and again
this could not get morning Sounion there
could be Oval Office recordings of the
president giving classified information
to a suspected Russian spy recruiter and
the context from those in the room and
this gets to the bragging part that Pat
mentioned Trump appeared to do this
to sort of boast about the great
intelligence that he gets how insecure
do you have to be to become president of
the United States and still brag about
job perks like intelligence briefings to
foreign diplomats and remember that this
meeting happened one day after Donald
Trump fired FBI director James Comey Lee
of course the guy investigating him so
it just gives the appearance at least
that he's sucking up to the ambassador
and the foreign minister there and when
you look at the Russian allegations does
that seem more or less likely after we
know this now absolutely and and the
counter is we'll listen if Trump really
were in bed with the Russians he
wouldn't be doing any of this because it
so obviously paints this picture of
collusion we don't know what Trump would
be doing in any circumstances because
he's got against what we would imagine
someone would do at just about every
step but you know what Pat so what Trump
leaked classified info to a suspected
Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office
who cares just get over that Hillary
loss right I mean the emails the Clinton
Foundation Obama wore a tan suit once
all these liberals need to stop talking
about this it seems as if Donald Trump
might be contradicting himself on this
one yes a rarity we've not seen that
happen ever before